there's this company called Sphero it
makes little remote-controlled toy balls
like this guy until recently most people
had never heard of it and then this
happened
this is bb-8 the cutest new asteroid
from the highly anticipated upcoming
Star Wars movie and sphero's ticket to
success until now Spiro sold 500,000
robots over four years about 14 robots
per hour when bb-8 was released on
September 4th that number shot up to
almost 2,000 per hour in one month
bb-8 sales have almost matched what
Sphero made in all of 2014
they're making a lot of money on this
robot if you didn't get it what are your
sales like now um
printing money like we sell every one of
these we make what it's changes your
company goes from like talking about how
do we ever get to 100 million dollars to
how do we get to a billion dollars
how did you get in with Disney how did
you get these robot balls from being
just robot balls becoming the hottest
toy of the season Disney was offering up
a new incubator right a seed incubator
for companies yeah are starting up so
every company is given their 15 minutes
of like fame with a mic right you get to
go meet Bob Iger to see your Disney so
we go into the meeting and you let us
show them all of our toys but then at
the very end Ian's like I have some
things to show you guys and that's when
he pulled this iPhone out and showed us
pictures from the set of Star Wars like
him and JJ Abrams next to this robot
there was like exactly our robot it was
like the most amazing thing you could
have ever imagined as a robot ball
company to see that the next Star Wars
droid is a robot ball and you're like
we've got this on lock that doesn't
necessarily mean things are going to end
well remember this cute but pretty
creepy robot my name is Teddy Ruxpin
three years after Teddy Ruxpin was the
it toy the company filed for bankruptcy
the company behind another one's beloved
toy Cabbage Patch dolls went bankrupt
five years after their big Christmas
fame and fortune might not last forever
but it really does seem like cute sells
well during the holidays what makes that
so cute I think the eyes that's like if
that's the difference right is the head
in the eyes yeah and this one is
significantly cuter than the other one
yeah it is significantly l-dopa then
it's okay sweetheart
it's okay you're still keep you're still
ready how many people do you think will
have bb-8 in their home I'm hoping
billions